dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here there are
two main branches of efficient smoke and
fluid simulator programs Alerian and
Lagrangian techniques before we dive
into what these terms mean I'd like to
note that we have closed captions
available for this series that you can
turn on by clicking the CC button at the
bottom of the player with that out of
the way the I'll Aryan technique means
that we have a fixed grid and the
measurement happens in the grid points
only we have no idea what happens
between these grid points
it may sound counterintuitive at first
because it has no notion of particles at
all with the Lagrangian technique we
have particles that move around in space
and we measure important quantities like
velocity and pressure with these
particles in short Alerian grids
lagrangian particles normally the
problem with all Aryan simulations is
that we don't know what exactly happens
between the grid points causing
information to disappear in these
regions to alleviate this they are
usually combined with Lagrangian
techniques because if we can also track
all these particles individually we
cannot lose any of them the drawback is
of course that we need to simulate
millions of particles which will take at
least a few minutes for every frame we
wish to compute by formulating his
famous equation the Austrian physicist
having Schrodinger won the Nobel Prize
in 1933 in case you're wondering yes
this is the guy who forgot to feed his
cat there's two important things you
should know about the Schrodinger
equation one is that it is used to
describe how subatomic particles behave
in time and two it has absolutely
nothing to do with large-scale fluid
simulations whatsoever the point of this
work is to reformulate Schrodinger's
equation in a way that it tracks the
density and the velocity of the fluid in
time this way it can be integrated in a
purely grid based Alerian fluid
simulator and we don't need to track all
these individual particles one by one
but we can still keep these fine small
scale details in a way that rivals
Lagrangian simulations but without the
huge additional costs
so the idea is absolutely bonkers just
the thought of doing this sounds so
outlandish to me and it works obstacles
are also supported by this technique
many questions still remain such as how
to mix different fluid interfaces
together how to model the forces between
them I do not have the pressures to see
the limits of the approach but I am
quite convinced that this direction
holds a lot of promise for the future I
cannot wait to play with the code and
see some follow-up works on this as
always everything is linked in the video
description box the paper is not only
absolutely beautifully written but it is
also a really fun paper to read and as I
read it I really loved how a jolt of
Epiphany read through me it is a
fantastic feeling when a light bulb
lights up in my mind as I suddenly get
to understand something I think it is
the scientists equivalent of obtaining
enlightenment may it happen to you
fellow scholars often during your
journeys and I get to spend quite a bit
of time every day reading fine works
like this it's a good life I'd like to
give a quick shout out to this really
cool website called short science which
is a collection of crowd-sourced short
summaries for scientific papers really
cool stuff make sure to have a look
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time